好了 我開始說吧
然後上週沒有講吧
然後再上週的話我們講了兩個點
就是一個是AI大週期
就是我覺得AI大週期
我們叫做Token需要遠遠超過Token Supply
這是一個半腦體和AI的大週期
第二我們上週講的一個是財政大週期
Physical Stem list
這不光是美國 包括中國 包括歐洲
和日本都在搞
今天我覺得結合美聯儲上個星期的決定
然後包括他FOMC給TradeFedout
和他一些經濟數據
我說一下中國和美國央行的一些糾結
就這個對於那個國家
或者我們叫Physical
政府層面的這個消費
其實相反的
因為央行還要考慮到一些通常的問題
所以
其實我們也看到J-PAL
J-PAL是應該是今天晚上美國時間會出來講話
然後在FOMC因為
新聞上是FOMC降了25個基點嘛
那我們之前也一直覺得9月份就是降25個點
今年兩次到三次
那就是今年大概是這樣一個格局
然後市場比較關心的是我們的terminal rate在哪裡
最終的利率在哪裡
然後這個中間就有到央行的一個糾結的決策了
那麼J-PAL是今天晚上會講話
之前那個FOMC的不少官員都開始陸陸續續的表達一些觀點
有一些比較強硬的
比方說BossTech
那麼他是覺得可能接下去降一次就可以了
然後
不要指望明年降息
那應該降一次
那這些比較極端的一些說法
但是我們看到的其實是這樣子
就是說央行的糾結在於通常
那麼我們先說美國吧
美國和中國的糾結不太一樣
但是有類似性
就是政府都在拼命的花錢
大家都知道Physical stimulus的這個財政周期
那個原來從08年開始
整個是貨幣市場去動的
就是那個整個解決通貨問題都是貨幣市場去動的
靠美聯儲營前
那個中國是央行和那個財政一起動力
美國主要是靠那個貨幣政策
但是這次財政政策在裡面起到特別大的作用之後
央行對於通脹一直是非常擔心的
那麼特朗普政府的政策在很多層面上是不可測的
待會我們會講到最近討論非常多的H&B的這個事情
那麼這是一個sample
那H&B到底有多大影響
其實對於這個總體
玩出去上沒有什麼影響
但是這個政策對於美國的科技優先性這些是會有影響
但是整體來說
從關稅政策到移民政策都有不確定性
然後這兩個政策其實都給到市場
就是這兩個政策都給到市場有可能會造成通脹上升
有可能會造成增長不足
而且特別是移民政策本身
移民政策的話它會導致就是說
我的失業率沒有特別大的變化
可能還是在4.3、4.3水平
但是我的就業能防配肉就會變得比較差
但那個能防配肉變得差的話
中間有一個就是移民一方面帶來消費
第二方面帶來工作
那你這個東西你比方說我們舉個最簡單例子
H&B現在美國把H&B就是僱主要花10萬美元
那這個大家都知道僱主花10萬美元
那麼我現在博士生和那個大學本科書士博士
在美國留學生畢業以後找工作
你本來的工資可能就10萬多美元吧
10萬美元可能還不到
那我為什麼要僱主要多花10萬美元去僱你啊
那就沒有人去僱務留學生了
那其實就是你被迫去採用美國國內的那些勞動力的話
那其實勞動力的需求是下降的
就是說我可能本來要可以僱三個人
現在僱兩個人可能是這個樣子
那麼H&B的這個政策我們待會再說吧
最近市場上對於H&B和對應於科技公司的影響
其實討論非常非常多的
那麼結果就是美聯儲在決策利率的時候
它的terminal rate是很難低於三個點的
就今年我們看到的通脹率PCE的話
可能就是在三個點上下三個點以下一點
那麼我沒有辦法把PCE降到三個點以下
所以很多人包括特朗普政府在市場上叫囂的
說我要把利率大規模下降
在任何一個聯儲手上都是做不到的
就是非常非常難以做的
就是我對於通脹沒有一個遠期的一個看法
這種情況下
而且一方面是這樣
另外一方面的話我們看到比方說
就業這個retail數據、銷售數據、經濟數據
並沒有特別特別差
因為Physical stimulus的結果是
企業盈利變得更好
企業盈利變得更好的話
公司股價都要上漲
包括我們開發S&P股價的波行高
美國的很多的消費或者我們叫做
整體的household balance sheet
資產負債表
你可以看到美國人的養老基金H&B
養老基金401K都是放在股票裡面的
那麼
其實大家的資產都在上升
就是公司盈利帶動大家資產上升
那其實消費並沒有差很多
你看到
其實上週的retail sales數據很沒有很差
所以
不同於傳統上的我們看到一旦消費數據
一旦那個就業數據下降
消費數據連著一起下降
然後通脹數據就下來
那麼現在政策性的導向
政府政策性的導向
包括政府消費包括政府解稅
包括政府加關稅包括政府移民政策
都使得這些東西不太清晰
這個是美國美聯儲面臨的問題
這個問題是JPL去面對的
然後也是下一任聯儲到26年相仁的下一任聯儲主席
都要去面對的問題
就是我現在沒有對於
白宮政策有一個非常明確的一個信號的情況下
我能夠做50個點和能做25個點
我一定叫keep options open
我一定把手上的牌先留住看你怎麼打牌我再決策
所以留25個點我覺得很正常
這次是不可能50個點
包括我能降能不降
在這個問題上我基本上先不降
就是先觀察以觀察為主
聯儲的主席不管誰上臺我覺得結果都一樣
白宮不可能控制沒聯儲的
就是派一個白宮清白宮的人
他最後也要為自己的身後名
為自己做的事情要負責的
你不可能搞出一個通脹
比方說我把利率降到3%一下
降到3%一下
那個就是real interest rate變成負的了
real interest rate變成負的情況下
那你萬一通脹起來怎麼辦
你明年再申席嗎
你要一秋萬年了
所以
任何一個聯儲主席都沒辦法做這樣的決定
就是
我們會看到央行在這些問題上的糾結
這個糾結是我覺得會持續的
隨著白宮政策不明確
我們說一下白宮政策怎麼不明確
你們看到他在關稅政策上
反反覆覆
這已經大家有目共睹
其實對於H1B的政策
那個H1B就是美國留學生
留美之後申請的工作簽證
工作簽證的
你可以看一下大家存量
大部分是印度人的
然後那個美加公司使用
其實這個中間包括了一大部分
這個美國最高端的人才能夠引入美國
都是H1B
那個你想博士生
博士生畢業那最後找到工作人
都都是用這個簽證
那麼
川普剛剛簽署這個政策的時候
那個商務部長Rutnik在旁邊
他是給press conference
就是給那個新聞記者說的是
我們要給所有現有的H1B這個 visa
要去收10萬美元的稅
還收10萬美元
然後還說一年10萬美元
而且明確的講
包括你轉
你比方說Meta轉到Google
你也要Google給我多叫10萬美元
就是多要這麼幹
那麼這個政策出來以後
其實很多大公司把國外的員工
全部找回來
就是這個東西政策太不可測了
那你我不知道這個
你入境的時候會不會再被卡
所以把這些人都找回來
一時間機票都沒了
但是問題是隔了兩天
那個白宮發言人Lavet
然後那個出來就是說
重新解釋了之前
那個商務部長的這個
這個這個對H1B的理解
他說不是
我們對於存量的東西不熟
所以你最後H1B的政策
是走成什麼樣子
包括川普的政策
他在移民上的政策
他在關稅上的政策
到底怎麼走
其實聯儲是不知道的
所以確實聯儲主席
現在是一個非常困難的角色
就是他還不同於中國
中國其實從央行到財政部
央行是絕對聽命於財政部
對吧
因為央行在中國是沒有獨立性的
那個央行出去
央行出去都給財政部要跪下來
所以財政部長發個聲音
央行行長是不敢放個屁
對吧
然後那個他們的政策是一致
那你跟著財政部
跟著那個老大走就行了
但是美聯儲
你還不知道就是白宮要幹嘛
所以他的政策就是
一直會有很大的不確定性
這個是央行的糾結
央行的糾結在背後
但是有一件事情
我覺得就我上週講的是缺陷
就是大量的發債
這個債務的發行的規模會比較大
那個我們看到
比方說big beautiful bill出來以後
其實big beautiful bill
對於明年的GDP的boost
可能在0.5左右
所以我們可能會看到
四季度和一季度
經濟數據會變差
但是從明年
明年整年的規劃來看的話
其實並不是很差的
那個這個不差的話
原因中間就是兩方面
一方面是政府的explanation
第二方面是這麼多公司的capax
我大話會講到AI的這個
幾個大的賓果案吧
AI的capax
所以我們回到利率上講
就是我們任何講到宏觀的話
都是講利率嘛
回到利率上
我們上週上兩週前
我是明確的覺得
利率走到極限
就是十年期利率走到極限
那個時候大概4%吧
我覺得4%絕對是個極限
就是在貨幣政策沒有確信
可以大規模放水
就這不太可能
然後財政上面是要花費
然後後面會出來大量的
這個債權供應的情況下
十年期利率在4%是個極限
就是no brainer
就是它會上去
就做空 做空債
做空債就是那個會上去
所以在聯儲公布降息之後
十年期利率就是4.14
4.14是不是一個
這個位置是不是
我覺得一個比較安全的位置
我覺得4.14不算特別安全吧
可能在4.1到4.25之間
我覺得這個是至少到今年年底
是一個比較安全和穩定的位置
就是我對債的一個看法
所以這一波的話
就是我當時也講了
就是可以去買些sorption
在4.4%左右買sorption
這個基本上是一個
我認為比較穩的一個交易
但現在4.1到4.25吧
我覺得這個可能是我對債市的看法
所以這個代表的是美國的貨幣政策的一個糾結
其實講到政府政策之後
講到中國的貨幣政策
其實我不想的話
他的評估講中國
因為中後面我覺得還有比較星辰大海的
這個美國的科技公司互相之間的這個投資
但是回應一下
我覺得攀空是完
因為9月24號去年是我們送了一個大禮包
央行說要設立平准基金
然後其實這幾天對於央行本來出來
央行中國經濟還是很差
像CPI還是負責嘛
然後出來就是大家非常希望中國繼續去印很多的錢
然後把股市寄入廠商去
過去一年股市是不錯
就是灰光反照了一把
然後覺得年底或者是明年是不是繼續可以掌握
我個人的看法是他們要寫折子跟聖上報平安了
就是現在這個位置上面
下面執行官員繼續去印錢
然後把股市或者資產繼續往上炒
對於他們個人的風險很大
這個和美國不太一樣
就是在中國的環境裡面
你做錯事情日後是要負責的
你滑了三條紅線
大家覺得你的政策不對
然後以後搞個事情把你抓進去了
對吧
滑三條紅線已經進去了
所以但這個滑三條紅線肯定不是他們
滑三條紅線肯定不是過數聽話的
滑三條紅線肯定是更高層的決策
但是問題是你在執行層面做過頭
日後有問題就會找你算帳
那麼現在貨幣政策和對於股市是相同的
包括吳清包括潘公生
他們這些人在臺上其實非常清楚的
就你現在中國股市是完全脫理基本面
基本面以他糊塗
那個中國
我就說那個地方政府
基本上那個地方政府併融
就相當於地方政府的非法幾次都已經有二十萬億了
那個曲線政府都是靠這些東西去不停的融資
然後繼續去搞工程
那個二三線城市基本全部是靠這個槓桿
就是現在中國的去槓桿沒有完成
然後加槓桿加不上去了
因為槓桿太高了
那個整個社會上面的這個融資
就是這個融資太大
然後背後是原來450萬億
現在可能跌到350萬億了
那350萬億的房地產在支撐
這個基礎資產上不去
我們的資產負債表就居民資產負債表
包括地方政府資產負債表都沒有辦法修復
你把股票炒上去
對宏觀的影響
你可以看到前面的CPI的
宏觀影響並沒有那麼的大
那麼繼續炒上去
就是貨幣政策繼續放水
然後再把股市炒上去
對這些人以後有可能會有風險
因為你怎麼上去你撐不住
也不像美國的這個公司
人家是EPS是盈利和馬程雙提高
盈利和盈利率雙提高
AI跟我們下面這兩個東西雙提高
帶動了它的上升
中國不是這個樣子
那麼這個情況下繼續去印錢
對於他們個人的風險很大
就是不是現在
現在你可以鼓吹
所以我覺得昨天的這個表態
其實是央行的表態
其實是這樣的
就是說我們做得非常好
現在包括央行包括那個證監會
都要這樣
就是像地摺子
說我們做了很好完成的工作
然後之前
其實布倫伯該出來一則新聞
這是上場主要
我就沒有講
布倫伯出來一則新聞說
那個上漲過快
倡導價值投資
倡導長期投資
無傾對於這個東西
就是一方面表示肯定
第二方面就是
其實他們內部自己
對於自己是有擔心的
所以我會覺得就是說
中國和美國都是一樣
就是政府的
政府的這個拆盤
就是Phytical Stimulus
是比較明確的
這是一個大周期
這個大周期是很長時間的大周期
它必須要靠這個東西
才能維持經濟
在百分之二點五以上增長
真是沒有辦法
那麼但是同時的話
央行的政策
大家都是比較
就是到了一個謹慎的節點
就是糾結的節點
就是它會不會硬
有可能會硬
但是他們都很糾結
這個是我對於中美的
宏觀的這個貨幣政策上的
一個大周期
那我說一下
HOMB我覺得
差不多沒有什麼可說的吧
因為我覺得政策
還沒有非常清晰
最後走生什麼樣子
不太清楚
但是至少按照現在政策來說
這些高技術移民
留美
就是至少留學生畢業留美
你幾乎不可能了
就很難很難
因為你要多花十萬美元
一個人多花
那這個誤人會比較困難
那我講一下
上週發生了幾個大的Deal
第一個就是
中國把Tetok給賣給了Oracle
Tetok本來的數據量
都是在Oracle上面
但是Oracle是等於是
幫Tetok做語音
懲處數據
它並沒有我們能力
拿Tetok這些數據
然後來做大量的Treating
然後Tetok賣給Oracle之後
給Oracle一個巨大的動力
Tetok是美國第一的短視頻
短視頻的網站
它不管以什麼價錢賣給Oracle
它的Augurism
就是把它的推薦算法的Augurism
就一併一併去給了美國
所以它這個Deal看樣子是這樣子
就是它的Ball的
將來在董事會裡面
還是需要大部分是美國
好像七個裡面五個是美國的
然後兩個是中國
就形式上給你中國保留20%
但是實際上就是賣給了
拿給了Oracle
加上應該是Seaw Lake
那個銀湖它們
所以它們控制了Tetok之後
Oracle會變成一個
就是另外一個崛起的Concolomerate
那麼在AI上面戰爭上面
我們講到過
上次講到過這個算力的大革命
這個是真正星辰大海的大革命
那個算力的需求
以指數級的帶增加
然後Token的需求
指數級的帶增加
說明AI背後是有指數級的需求
人體的需求在推動它
算法也是在指數級的在優化
就是那麼要繼續優化AI的背後
就是需要大量的這個算力的投入
那原來我們就
我上次我發過一個推講的一個故事
就好像在二戰的時候
你開戰的時候
剛剛開戰的時候
比方蘇芬戰爭
你還是看精兵政策
蘇聯在芬蘭死了30萬人
那個動用了上百萬人
對吧
芬蘭用幾萬人
因為精兵政策
那麼就好像我們在不同的
我們看到不同的模型
其實這個中間還是模型
誰做模型做得好
但是到了後期
其實是打了總動員戰爭
總動員戰爭就是
我誰的產能大
就是我用產能給你碾壓了
美國造了166艘航空母艦
那個算力革命上也是
就是最後誰有大規模的這個算力
誰能夠取勝
那個大模型最後可能
就規輯到幾個大的
很高的手上
甚至我覺得OpenAI
然後比方說Google
然後就可能就沒有什麼了
就是可能
可能Microsoft和那個Microsoft的那個
我拍了再混一下
然後Android再混一下
然後那個上週的這個Deo是TikTok先去
Alloco先去吃了TikTok
同時的話Alloco去買了那個NVDN
大量的算力
那個買了大概1000億的算力
其實大家都要說他左腳踩右腳
但我覺得這個並不是左腳踩右腳
因為Alloco買了1000億的NVDN算力
NVDN投了1000億到OpenAI
然後OpenAI又去買了Alloco的這個Token
就是他算力的放到Alloco上面
其實最後達成的變成的是一個什麼東西
就是這1000億投入
變成了他算力的這個
就是算力戰爭的這個資源
變成OpenAI的算力
算力戰爭的資源
其實Sam Altman我記得在去年的時候
就講過一個理念
他要說要投7萬億美元
投7萬億美元的算力
然後進行這個AI的計算
就是大規模的集群計算
其實包括硅谷大部分的這個
經營的看法都是
我們不管中我幹什麼事情
無所謂他們幹嘛什麼
製造業都無所謂
我們只要把AI戰爭給打贏了
我們就贏了
所以在AI戰爭中間怎麼打贏
我們就是大規模的算力投入
其實AI戰爭就是幾個大的
科技集團之間的戰爭
那最後可能有一些
一開始很牛的小公司
比方說Groch
比方說XAI
那麼他們算力不夠
那就最後就是被OpenAI集隊掉
那人家後面有Stargate
人家後面有那個
人家後面有NVIDIA
然後有大量的這個資金的投入
可能就是變成幾個大的concrete
現在看上去的話
我覺得一個非常大的集團正在形成
一個就是NVIDIA 英偉達
然後加上Oracle
然後加上OpenAI
OpenAI還和蘋果之前有那個
有那個Alliance就是有那個關聯
所以這是一個巨大的一個集團
然後另外一方面的可能有那個
可能有谷歌
谷歌加阿瓦狗
阿瓦狗是幫谷歌做TPU的嘛
所以他們可能是一個集團
就是你會看到這幾個大的集團
正在形成
每一次這些大集團
動用大規模的這個算力投入
你想中國最近在說
它要投5000億好像是那個涉容
然後支持中
中間有一部分支持中小企業
然後中間有一部分支持農業什麼的
5000億人民幣
那個NVIDIA和NVIDIA和那個
和OpenAI的底有中間
就是建立的算力中心
就是10個GagWatt
10個GagWatt是當當於什麼
三峽三分之一
三峽的一半
三峽的一半的電力
是這樣的一個算力中心
所以那個是1000億美元
就是這個你就會看到
就是它的生產量
就是它的產能生產量和它的這個
大家芯片也肯定也比你先進很多
你這個航母機片都打不出來
你的那個華為路徑都走錯了
但是你質量和數量
都是跟人家差數量級的
就是你會看到
它有這麼大的這個頭論
最後AI就是可能會陸陸這幾個大的集團
就是這兩個大的集團手上
這個是非常新陳大海的一些變化
其實我聽到消息後面還有還會有
就是最近還會有
那個NVIDIA一方面是去投了OpenAI
NVIDIA另外一方面還去投了Intel
其實我因為一直比較看好Intel
我覺得它價值嚴重低估
那麼我多說一下Intel的事情
其實是這樣
就是去年當那個三毛產品去找到
包括台積電的時候
就是張忠謀也把它給掉了
就是你需要這麼大的頭路
後面需要大量的產能的出產
那你可以把談積電想成油框
就二戰的時候油框都在美觀
那台積電就是油框
最後都是需要現代工業
最後都是需要能源
當時一樣道理就是現代算力
你最後都是需要芯片
那芯片只有台積電能產
談積電是不可能願意去
為了你這個夢想去大規模的去投入
它的模式很簡單
我前面的客戶需要
然後我根據客戶的需要
我慢慢投產
你要指數級的我投產
沒人敢幹這個事情
台積電不敢
那麼他們就傳給這個局面
然後那個NVIDIA把Intel給投了
然後其實就是一方面倒閉台積電
一方面看這個
有沒有第二個Othernity的選擇
能夠給出芯片的公益
現在就是最後
搶到最後的脖子
就是芯片的公益
就是我能夠出產多少片
然後搶這個芯片的公益
然後再去搶這個算力
搶完算力中心搶芯片公益
搶完算力中心搶完芯片公益之後
前面的這個模型公司去搶算力
就這個就是一個supply constraint
然後大家再是上千億美元
上千億美元
甚至上萬億美元
現在美國這些科技公司的Kipax投入
都是加在一起上萬億美元
那個大規模的這個算力投入
那對應於中國那些公司的話
我覺得這樣形成大海的投入
根本沒有可能一些
你看看阿里斯一共才兩四千多億
所以這個跟他們相比的話
就是有點小
但是你會看到現在美國
整個在規股掀起的這個大規模的投入潮
和大規模的其實聯盟並構潮
是會形成超級巨大的科技公司
我適用我會形成超級超級巨大的科技公司
而且這個對整個產業國家的影響
是不可估量的
就會非常非常大
然後有一些前期比看去比較牛的公司
有可能在這個
我們叫做就是戰爭的模式被改變了
在這個偷偷握全面戰爭動員
全總動員戰爭中間
會被會被淘汰掉
會慢慢落伍
就總動員戰爭中間一定是最大的winner takes off
我個人感覺
所以我們拭目以待
我是聽說關於英草和那個幾個科技公司
會有新一輪的這個信息
就他們可能會有一些東西出來
好
最後5分鐘我說一下
昨天可能這邊觀看B圈內比較多吧
昨天那個看到一臺訪報店
就整個整個Crypto市場報店
但是比較翻臉的是
比較有意思的是那個黃金是漲了
所以並不是說
我因為貨幣政策或流動性不足
或是什麼原因
就是為什麼避權報店
那我給一個我個人看法
就是是這樣子
你看到那個Bitmine
這個公司融了3億美元
然後Bitmine公司融了3億美元
他給的是一家14%
應該是70塊錢吧
就是賣了賣了這個3億美元的股票
然後3億多
我具體數字忘了
那麼但是這個Deal
就是你看上去股價是一價的
所以大家沒有道理說
我買了股票把股票賣掉對吧
但是同時的話
他買股票他送了Option
送了7權
那你就這樣算
按星期五收拾價來算的話
你直接把Option賣掉
再加把股票賣掉
你能轉完這25到30
這是一個NoBrainer的Deal
就是我只要把股票能給你賣掉
然後把7權給你賣掉
7權肯定
就是這都流通市場可以隨便賣了
我把這兩個東西一賣
然後我就立馬能夠轉手
獲利20%到25%到30
那我為什麼不做呢
那我完成這個配認購股票
肯定會參與
只要給我參與我把你立馬參與
參與完以後
市場如果沒有可以賣出股票機會
我就先把一切去給Shout了
做空欄的吧
我把一切去給Shout了以後
等到每股開市的時候
我再把這個股票
我再把這個股票給賣掉
把一切就通倉給評掉
所以這是一個對沖行為
就是你們覺得這個是左腳踩右腳
那個Tom Lee他可以永遠踩下去
你錢得要從地方來的
這些錢來的這個錢
可能並沒有市場上那麼多美元的錢
對ETH有這麼明確的看法
你得折家賣你的股票
文化要拿的折家賣股票
其實它做的並不像
它沒有那個
那個MACO strategy的這個能力
MACO strategy人家的能力是能夠賣債
它不是賣股票
它是能賣債
債上面加了option
那這個就是說
你的畢竟你買進option的時候
你對沖的投存沒那麼大
你賣股票
人家直接把你證股全部的給對沖了
你賣3億
你就賣出去3億
所以不一定到3億吧
但是你賣證股的話
我大部分投存都會在市場上賣掉
所以你人與世折家賣股票
那你就市場就毫無留情的
你在每股沒開市的時候
先把你以太棒給砸掉
先砸上去
我就先套利
套利指引我
就是落貸為安
我就落貸為安了
到了第二天
我再把股票賣一賣
把那個以太坊的空倉投存拼一拼
所以幣圈現在大部分的
幣圈現在大部分的
我們叫做價格引導
並不是你們看得到的
就是說幣安上看了多少
多單看了多少空單
然後我看了一些什麼數據
或者宏觀的什麼這些東西
其實很多的主流幣的Presaction
都已經定價都是在華爾街了
然後都是和很多華爾街的
套利的那些策略相關
其實大家也沒有對
比方說以太坊
或者是你搞不這麼多BNB的智庫
也沒有對這個東西有真正的
北塔就是方向性的看法
其實你只要給我利套
然後我就會給你套掉
所以這是我對以太坊的
那個昨天的這個Axe的一個理講
我給你們分享一下我自己的看法
好吧
我們今天先半小時講到這裡
然後看看大家有什麼問題
然後我們